we all choose our path light
or dark freedom or destruction
the empire chose to destroy alderaan in
order to spread fear
and douse the fires of rebellion but the
heroic pilots of the rebel alliance have
chosen to keep
fighting to show the empire that we are
not
afraid it was their bravery that ended
palpatine's reign
and brought about our new republic
however
the empire lives on shattered though it
may be
as i speak imperial forces are edging
toward the bormier sector
hoping to end our new republic before we
find our footing
as their empire collapses they try to
tighten their grip
but the galaxy is changing and you can
be a part of it
with the help of brave and daring pilots
this war can
end make a choice fly with the new
republic
change our galaxy for the better
hi i'm suzanne hunca narrative producer
on star wars squadrons
our single-player story is one of daring
pilots and deep-seated rivalries
take titan squadron hunt down the
starhawk
and eliminate it gladly add more sloan
over the course of the story you'll fly
as two pilots on
opposite sides of the war and like all
modes in star wars squadrons
you'll have the option to experience
every mission fully immersed in vr
right antilles rogue squadron i hear
you're the reason i was able to finally
get a calm through
today we're giving you a glimpse of an
early imperial mission
behind enemy lines one of our spies
agent thorne has discovered vital
intelligence on project starhawk
your mission is to extract her from an
orbital outpost above hosni and prime
behind enemy lies you'll have to
eliminate perimeter defenses
when you've secured the area you will
escort the gladius to the outpost
and our extraction team will acquire
agent thorne
once thorn is secure reach your gozanti
cruisers and return to the overseer
i'll handle it
you have my thanks titan squadron no
time to celebrate
move on
each mission will immerse you into the
escalating conflict between the new
republic
and a shattered empire debrief with your
squad mates between missions you're our
new wingmaid
customize and master all eight
starfighters and join the galaxy's
finest
i need you focused and ready to go
from bombing runs at the nadiri
dockyards
to setting a trap in the xavian abyss
the story of these rival squadrons will
push the war to the brink
and define the galaxy for years to come
i look forward to seeing you in combat
october 2nd
you